hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the second
official formal charge which is being
brought against Socrates during his
trial recorded in Plato's apology is of
impiety yeah this is an offense against
the religion that's being practiced by
the Athenians it's felt to be an offence
not just against say religious authority
or religious sentiments but against the
gods themselves so it's being brought no
longer simply on the side of those who
are being injured you know as in
corrupting the young but on the side of
look you're you're actually doing
something harmful that something wrong
something scandalous with respect to our
traditional religion of the city and
Socrates says you know we really ought
to clarify what what exactly you mean
been bringing these charges against me
mellitus I think some of this could
actually get cleared up if we just know
what would it in fact you actually mean
by this so one possibility would be that
Socrates is actually an atheist and an
atheist in the sense that he doesn't
think there's anything supernatural
there's nothing divine it can all be
explained by philosophical or
metaphysical or what we would nowadays
call scientific
counts of things and there were in fact
some people very rare but there were in
fact some people at the time who were of
this bent he's gonna bring up an exam
will come come back to him in a moment
and there were plenty of people who are
sort of practically speaking atheist in
that the gods didn't really have any
important role in their life and they
sort of have the view of ah gods sure
mods just just figments of people's
imagination and latest does seem to
think that Socrates is doing that at
first another possibility would be that
he's introducing some some radically new
gods that he shouldn't be doing and this
is not really that big of a deal for the
Greeks that ends up being much of a much
bigger problem for the city of
monotheistic religions but the Greeks
were actually quite happy when they saw
somebody engaged in some sort of worship
that they didn't understand to do one of
two things one was quite often to say
you know that that guy over there looks
kind of like Zeus and I think they have
kind of the same function of Zeus we're
gonna call him such-and-such Zeus or
such-and-such Hermes or such-and-such
Apollo so you get all these Zeus's and
Apollo's all over the place that was one
way that they dealt with it another way
was actually to take out on the religion
say well I guess we left something out
you know we're only human we don't know
all the divine these guys over there
they they have a cult that maybe we'll
incorporate so that's not really a big
deal but Socrates isn't actually doing
anything like that if anything he's more
of a critic of the traditional poetic
traditional religious conception of the
gods we can see this in a number of the
dialogues doesn't come up in here though
the other possibility is that he's
introducing just the broader category of
other gods and so maybe he's really got
in a very philosophical way which
precludes the kind of worship and
relationships that
ordinary people or you know right
thinking Athenian citizens would have at
the gods and I think there is some
plausibility to this when you when you
read something like the Euthyphro or you
read parts of the Republic Socrates
really is advancing a conception of the
gods that is along the same lines as
some of the other people who saw the
gods as being unduly anthropomorphic as
you know doing a lot of things that
human beings want not to be doing so
therefore those are probably fables and
Socrates doesn't actually defend himself
against that in his discussion of these
charges latest doesn't really catch that
either the no gods part that's dealt
with pretty early and I'm not even gonna
call this an argument because what
Socrates does he says look Meletis you
know that I think that the Sun and the
moon their gods right and milena says no
you don't you think that they're their
rocks are they're their natural items or
things like that and Socrates says this
is a case of mistaken identity buddy and
you really don't know what you're
talking about because see there's this
guy an exact arrest you can buy his
Scrolls you know books or Scrolls back
then you can buy his Scrolls in the
marketplace for you know whatever amount
and you know if you unroll them when you
actually read it you'll see that he the
sort of things that you're saying right
there that's the stuff he says so I'd
basically be plagiarizing and people
would laugh at me if I were to say that
these were my ideas and you know when
they're really hangs a grass is and so
he's got him there
I mean if Molina's wants to say the
socrates doesn't believe in any gods
whatsoever because he espouses a natural
physicalist theory of things clearly he
has the wrong person in mind he hasn't
done his homework what's more
interesting why are the two arguments
that Socrates gifts and this one is a
little bit you know
not well-formulated but it's a little
bit confusing in the text as well here's
the most important argument that
Socrates gives he says look when we talk
about human activities we believe that
there are human beings that actually do
these human activities right so if
somebody believes in human activities
he's got to be believing that human
beings exist even if we want to like you
know make up stuff like spinning tops
that that you know tell fables or
something along those lines if we want
to you know talk about those sorts of
things we have to kind of believe in
something like that but you know when it
comes to human beings I mean we know
that there's human beings like there's a
whole jury of them I'm doing something
human right now and you're doing
something human right now
got you that far right and Mileena says
yeah that that's right well I mean who
talks about divine activities or
supernatural activities they own you
know things that are that are
transcendent you could say that are
manifesting divinity if you're going to
talk about that sort of stuff
that implies that there actually are
divine beings that those matters concern
so if we're gonna say something like you
know the loom of fate is that just a
metaphor or do we really think of fate
as is this you know a woman working at a
loom if we if we have these stories
about them presumably the stories are
about something if there are divine
matters there's got to be divine beings
that those matters come from and so I
actually says but look I do believe that
there's divine matters I talk about them
I say some things are divine or there's
a bit of the divine and uh sir I have
all sorts of things that I talk about
this way how about my divine sign that
tells me you know whether I should do
something or not do something generally
just whether you shouldn't do something
um I heard an Oracle I think
you know if you have an Oracle and you
want to call it an Oracle it's got to be
coming from a god otherwise just call it
you know
gibberish uttered by some lady inhaling
in feels so Socrates does believe in
divine activities there's a little bit
more to the argument than this because
he gets mellitus to say you know he goes
through a process where he says look
either these divine activities are
coming from the gods or from beings that
are descended from the gods if it's the
gods that I got you right there I do
believe in the gods you're not gonna get
me out in piety if it's the children of
the gods or beings that came from the
gods
well you just bump the problem one step
down the road because now I'm going to
ask you well where did those come from
if I believe in children of the gods
don't I have to believe in the gods if I
don't if I don't believe in the gods how
are there going to be anything that we
could call children of the gods like
demigods for example the heroes right so
this is a pretty good argument you know
as well they just once they actually
claim that Socrates doesn't believe in
anything divine and Socrates says well I
do because I believe in divine
attributes or activities and those refer
to divine things that's a pretty good
argument it doesn't get him off the hook
of maybe re understanding the gods in a
different way though and my latest let's
that slide in parsimonious ISM you know
very good at this sort of thing
the second argument I just call I'm on a
mission from God and I actually have a
core concept video specifically about
this Socrates is making the case that
look I have to believe in God if I'm on
a mission from God and what's your
evidence for that well look at I'm
willing to die for what it is that that
I'm doing I think that it's so important
I obeyed my superiors orders in warfare
when they said you need to go out and
fight at Potidaea I didn't throw my
shield away and run away and say
I'd rather live I'd rather not take on
any danger I obeyed those orders and so
I'm gonna even more obey orders that are
coming from God how can you doubt that I
believe in the gods when in fact undoing
their work
now you could say well let's get a
little bit more specific Socrates which
God's work are you doing and there he
can say Apollo because - went - you know
the story clarified went to the the
Oracle and asked know who's the wisest
man in Greece or is Socrates the wisest
man in Greece and the Oracle gave a
response so Socrates says that the God
ie Apollo who's giving a response there
so maybe of it maybe socrates doesn't
necessarily believe in Athena and
Artemis and Hades and all those others
that's a little unclear at this point
but clearly he does in fact believe in
at least one God because he's taking
orders from him and he's refusing to
stop doing that even though people are
telling him hey this is dangerous for
you because he thinks that that's what
the city needs he's actually a gift from
God to the city so these are the these
are the defenses against the charge of
impiety like I said you know if mellitus
if Plato had allowed and the latest to
be a little bit more on the ball in the
dialogue there are some places where he
could have pushed and said look Socrates
your conception of God is radically
different than the ordinary Athenians so
we're still going to charge you with in
piety and their Socrates might not have
had a good response other than to say
well here's the case for why I think I
you know mind my way of seeing in his
best but he doesn't do that and so I
think that this is a pretty successful
defense against that charge of impiety